there I mean there are um some terms
that Aristotle makes up
um he's not quite so mysterious with it
as Hyer is I think Hyer kind of likes to
do that to I mean heyer's basic stick is
ah our language is inadequate so I have
to come up with these these things um in
order to make this uh this work um
but um when he does make up a term it
it'll he'll see if there's something
available so like think back to when
we're talking about right ambition
Aristotle says that the proper
disposition is nameless and that within
his Society there's only two terms
there's
unambitious a philotimia and then
there's uh ambitious philotimia seeking
out Desiring honor
and that one is at one extreme and the
other is at the Other Extreme and that
what we want is really in the in the
middle um he also he says this about one
other virtue and I'm blanking on the one
that he he does but he's um he's not
inclined to like say okay I need to make
up a whole new term you know he he tries
to see if there's something so yeah
you're like you're right he's he is like
saying do we have anything like this
already you know there's a bigger issue
here actually when it comes to what we
call moral
vocabulary
um I think we suffer from
having maybe too many terms that people
use in too many different ways in our
society right and so Lighting on the
right
description of an action or a series of
actions that we call a compartment you
know that are reflective of a person's
character
um that's really quite important and a
lot of people in our society and I think
throughout time are very sloppy with
this and you do see a lot of
attentiveness to this proper description
throughout moral philosophy so like St
anom for example in his works you'll
notice him saying we should rightly
describe this action this way rather
than this way and then if we if we do
describe it the right way the puzzles
about it start to you know break down
Thomas aquinus actually calls this the
moral species of an act the the the uh
the species being the type right so if I
so let's say we take something where
there's like a story to be told you see
me go up and punch somebody in the face
and you're like oh that's a wrongful
action look at him he just walked right
up and cold that guy right so
walking up and cold cocking that guy is
a description of an action and then
let's say Harold says oh no no you
missed the the first part of it that guy
was um uh throwing um darts at him and
you know one of the darts hit didn't hit
him but it it hit his kit in in the head
and stuck into his kid's head right and
then you're then you're like well okay
so now he wasn't just cold cocking the
guy he was retaliating against
aggression now that's a different
description right and we evaluate these
in very different ways and then let's
say you know um somebody else so
Martin's here Martin comes along and
Martin says oh yeah but what you failed
to realize is this guy actually had um
Greg sign a
waiver um because this is a dart
throwing
Zone we get better and better
descriptions about what's going
on when we do that we can we can
evaluate the moral species of the ACT we
can say what it essentially is
and you see like Emmanuel Kant doing
this with his you know concern about
what is the maxim of Your Action right
so you know the the language that we use
to describe things is is incredibly
important and and and this fits in one
last thing to say about this Aristotle
in the rhetoric seems to be a little bit
cynical even in the the topics because
he's like well because you could
describe an action multiple ways if you
have to defend somebody in court you you
say they weren't trying to deliberately
harm this person they were doing this
instead they were doing this other thing
right so yeah AR Aristotle um I mean he
will he will coin some new
terms um you know consider like ana um
which can be activity or function or all
all these different things um that's him
using a philosophical VOC vocabulary
that he's pushing just as a last thing
on this I think too many people
in contemporary analytic philosophy and
contemporary Continental philosophy like
to invent
terms um when it's they don't need to if
they were
better I don't want to say philosophers
but better if they were more articulate
they would just be able to find some
language that actually works for it
without having to like make up a new
term sometimes you need to like so Harry
Frankfurt died recently right I think
all of you know that news and what he's
really well known for is this idea of
second order
desires not a totally new idea you know
people have talked about this before but
he saw um the importance of the
phenomenon and then he thought okay we
need to be able to describe this in some
way um but you notice that he's he's
using he's using two terms that were
already existing
within the language and he's not using
him in some weird way you know some
idiosyncratic way he's he's uh doing
what analytic philosophy when it's good
stuff is is doing sort of clarifying the
language you
know